we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine to david p here's
a voicemail i received hi David I want
you to know that not all of your
listeners are young or even middle-aged
I'm almost 81 and I love your show
thanks very nice voicemail Louis you
know it's usually two to three weeks of
just horrible horrible things being said
about me or my family or me personally
or just crazy unhinge comments it's nice
to hear from a nice nearly 81 year old
woman who's a fan of the show every once
in a while of course yeah and uh
apparently you haven't angered her to
the point where she's turned to hate
riete ism no not yet although maybe her
next appearance on the show will be on
hatred mail rather than the voicemail
segment if heard if I if the third tone
changes although this seems like a bit
genuinely nice woman I don't sounds very
nice yeah let's talk about today's bonus
show we will talk about the discarded
food problem we've talked about this
before Lewis has told the stories from
his time working in a produce department
at a grocery store about how bad the
discarded food problem is in the u.s. we
have now learned it is even worse than
we thought additionally the Department
of Justice confirms that Baltimore
police are not necessarily the best
people we're gonna go into those details
based on that report the only way to get
access to the bonus show is by being a
david pakman show member and of course
you can sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership and there are two
coupons left the coupon code is beta 50b
ETA 50 and if you enter that code it'll
only work two more times you will get a
fifty percent discount off of your
membership for life and that is uh it's
a wonderful thing louis so on monday we
announced the new david pakman show
website i announced that we had a coupon
code that could be used 25 times it has
been used 23 times and only two remain
my prediction louis is this is the last
we will ever hear of that coupon code
because i believe by tomorrow morning by
this time tomorrow afternoon in fact
because i want clarity uh there will be
no more coupons to be to be known of
it's perfectly possible that by the time
people even hear this those two coupons
will have been used
but hopefully not okay well Louis
painting of a sort of satyr pond code
but yet that is uh that is also possible
check it out david pakman.com slash
membership I think the bonus show is
better than ever at this point it's um
yeah I better than the regular show for
sure yo well then that's a probably
different conversation to have a
different day we will talk to you on the
bonus show follow me on twitter at d
pakman we are on facebook facebook.com
slash david pakman show